oh hello little frog hate to embarrass
you like this but your insides are
showing you're okay with that all right
then I guess that's why they call you
the glass frog you can find over 150
species of glass frogs and the
rainforests of Central and South America
it's so translucent you can even see its
beating heart and it's not just the
stomach that's see-through if you look
hard enough
you can even see through some species
legs and glimpse their bones and here we
see the special adult time of the glass
frog as well as the eggs inside the
female's belly
so why the transparency the truth is
scientists aren't really sure it could
play some part in camouflage regardless
the glass frogs green coloration
definitely helps it blend in and check
out these eyes kind of weirdly for a
frog they point straight ahead as
opposed to sitting on the sides of the
face that might help the glass frog
target prey like insects right in front
of it so there you have it the glass
frog the rainforests greatest advocate
for transparency though not necessarily
invisibility